bring it on it went on to bank over 90
million dollars at the box office
and we're cheering on its premiere 20
years ago today
[Music]
[Applause]
i want to give my heart and soul into
this the tauros clovers and of course
spirit fingers bring it on became an
instant team classic when it premiered
in 2000
and it was a breakout role for a then 27
year old gabrielle union
here you all come trying to steal it
putting some blonde hair on it and
calling it something different
it gave me a chance to provide a black
girl in the lead
that you know young minority people can
look up to because we haven't had that
you're usually just like the best friend
like
some kind of peripheral role this is not
a democracy it's a chirocracy kirsten
dunst was 18 at the time
balancing being a working actress while
still in high school
i got to go to prom graduation football
games but i was still getting to do what
i love to do so i was happy
i'm not saying it's going to be easy
it's going to be hard work
we went through four weeks of
cheerleading boot camp we just worked
our butts off learned a lot of dances
and
tried to learn stunts
i called it hell they called it
cheerleading camp eight nine ten hours a
day
of just nothing but cheer
[Applause]
i have the outfit it does not fit but
soon one day i'd like to think that one
day came last year
gabrielle rocked the clover's uniform
with her daughter cavia for halloween
bring it kirsten is now engaged and has
a two-year-old son with jesse plemmons
aka landry from friday night lights and
he's a fan of kirsten's cheer classic
be like when i was younger that movie
was just always on
yeah i've seen it quite a few times